well it's obviously much quieter than it
was exactly a year ago people are now
being processed they're coming through
and the british and american soldiers
are working together trying to keep
these khan these people here have a look
[Music]
uh this is the
baron gate this is the area that people
were brought in to be processed by the
british military
still a restricted area
um
they don't really like you filming here
at all and just beyond here you can see
and it's hardly changed in the year uh
the canal uh where a lot of people were
killed in a suicide bomb attack which
basically brought this rather chaotic
evacuation to an end
the taliban have been here a year now
they're totally in control but this
still feels like a country that's not
quite sure where it's going in any sort
of sense or form
[Music]
the war is over but there isn't peace
yet
well there are still checkpoints
everywhere in cardboard what's
interesting though of course they're now
being manned by the taliban
and they're still using the
paraphernalia and equipment that the
foreign forces put in the blast walls
security blocks etc
and
one year on while ostensibly there's no
war here anymore
security is still very very high islamic
state are carrying out bomb attacks on a
regular basis and it's likely to get
worse as we enter this sort of
anniversary period of the taliban
takeover but it is interesting that
although the foreign soldiers have gone
the taliban have just taken over and is
using their positions
as we make our way through the centre of
kabul there is stark evidence of the
deep economic crisis here
those considered middle class now
struggle to make ends meet
in this upmarket district of the capital
women wait for bread to be handed out
they're desperate
on the side of the road people are
selling their belongings
people are bringing their
household goods uh for sale everything
you know hoover here and an old
microwave
yeah we have car boot sales in the uk
obviously but this is different these
people are actually bringing their
entire houses
for sale i was talking to one guy who
was saying that it breaks his heart
because he's actually literally cleared
out the lounge
for sale here but that's because the
economy is in virtual freefall they
don't have any jobs so this is the only
way they can get any money
okay
episode
in this country a carpet is vital
without one your home will be very cold
in the winter when nights drop well
below freezing
the temperature will start to fall in
just a couple of months
[Music]
the withdrawal of foreign aid and
freezing of afghanistan's assets has
plunged the health service into a daily
crisis
here at the indira gandhi children's
hospital the doctors are fighting a
medical emergency every hour
healthcare in afghanistan particularly
in the provinces has been poured for
decades that isn't the issue here the
point is we're in the best children's
hospital in the whole of the country and
they're overwhelmed they just don't have
the resources they don't have the money
they don't have medicines and
many of the children who come here are
simply going to die not because they
couldn't be treated but because there is
no way of treating them they need
international community help
well the flags of the taliban are
everywhere perhaps poignantly this is
the u.s embassy it's effectively been
mothballed uh but they're totally in
control this is isaf headquarters i used
to come here constantly the interesting
things we've been here for about 10 or
15 minutes filming and nobody stopped us
a year ago that wouldn't have been
allowed in fact for the
tens of years that i came here you would
never have been able to stop and film
here sort of really interesting how
things have changed
outside the now empty foreign embassies
of the green zone we met some men from
helmand they're here to celebrate the
taliban takeover
did you ever think this day would come
where
you'd be celebrating
one year on from the takeover did you
ever think this would happen
the taliban and its supporters may be
celebrating
but for others here life is only getting
harder